[Applause]
what's up everybody
schultzy here akash singh alex media
mark gagnon
another episode of uh flagrant two we
got a lot of things to talk about man
um a lot a lot of things happening in
the comedy world
la comedy scene taking yet another
another hit bro um
yeah dude there's like a corona me too
virus going
they need to put the la comedy in a
bubble bro
[ __ ] is getting [ __ ] is getting harsh
out there man
yo rogan got out just in time
broken was like [ __ ] this i'm not
sticking around
to watch this [ __ ] scene it's crazy
no is it it's crazy what's what's going
down i mean uh
uh i want to get into it we'll probably
get into it a little bit later
uh but uh my man callum um
man la times caught up
i mean this chick accused him of rape
bro it was it was hard to read i thought
it was really
easy to read it was beautifully written
like
like it was oh it was hard to read yeah
oh
okay i thought you were criticizing the
girls writing wouldn't that be some [ __ ]
if you're going to accuse her rape at
least you know put it eloquently son
this girl wrote a law and order sv
i think she even had the dungeons
bro it was insane the detailing like the
detailing was so
so good like i was like was she in
entertainment
like i was like she had to be part of
the industry there's no way
yeah there's no way i have never agreed
with a trigger warning until now
what do you mean if i went through that
[ __ ] and then i was reading about it i'd
be like yo this is
exactly like what i went through like
this is entirely too descriptive
this is horrifying to relive bro it was
we gotta contact that writer like
that writer need a book deal bro that
right we need a book deal that writer
need to write the ellen degeneres
biopic or some [ __ ] we're going to talk
about ellen too but
but yeah man so i called cala and i was
like bro just break this down to me like
what's going on he's telling me yeah i
want to hit him
and uh i don't want to say anything
until i know what calling is saying yeah
he's like nah
it was [ __ ] you know it's completely
he knew the girl he knew the girl from
five years before that
they went out on a date she had a
boyfriend he didn't know that she had a
boyfriend right this is what counts as
it's not what i'm saying this is only
information that's out there and um
you know they were hooking up whatever
and then then uh you know she felt i
guess didn't want to
you know keep hooking up he said okay
that's cool that's fine
stopped everything's good later on
they talk she auditions to play his wife
on a show
he reads with her chemistry read
not just audition chemistry read means
if you get the role that day
you already signed the contract for
seven years
that you're going to be now i'm not
saying that that doesn't mean
it could have happened everybody wants
opportunities it's a small business you
got to take the opportunities that
you're given
yeah 100 that being said like
in his mind he was saying to me i'm so
blown away by it because
we continue to talk like there are
plenty other times where we met at
auditions hung out she was auditioned
for his show there are all these other
times
so it would to him it was like this is
crazy obviously
he put out his piece and i thought it
was good that he put out a piece
i didn't see his piece actually oh yeah
he put out a piece i saw a statement
from him is that what you meant no he
put on instagram oh [ __ ] yeah which i
think
here's the thing i think a lot of people
get [ __ ] up about this stuff and again
i don't know anything i can only share
with you guys what callan said to me
right he said not even
no chance no absolutely not et cetera
which is
obviously what you're gonna say yeah
some people are a little quiet and that
that can read guilty whether it's real
or not
some people are very quiet and you're
like well you're being a little quiet
about being accused of some heinous [ __ ]
so that's what i'm saying the fact that
he went out and did a video he did a
front facing video we can even
get it up and uh yeah show his new
eyelids he got he did eyelids
maybe that's why he did front facing
videos everybody else did have written
everybody else did like a written in
front of one of those [ __ ] lights in
the instagram
[Applause]
the right lid is a little tight they
took a little too much off the right lid
in my opinion
but uh i told you my theory i think he
tried to get in front of the story by
doing a cartel thing where they changed
their face up
so do you need to get a new apple face
do you need a redo face id if you got
new eyelids
i wonder because they might be like yo
who's this big eyelid
[ __ ] yeah
yeah that's interesting because with the
mask your [ __ ] doesn't work
nope it's a possibility anyway so he
does this video
it's too long for us to watch the whole
thing but um
do you want to watch any of it no not
really
i don't care you should have watched it
so uh so uh
it basically says i didn't do it that's
what it says i didn't do it and it's
like
why the [ __ ] is he the first person to
come out with the video
that's like i didn't do it i don't know
why everybody should everybody comes out
with like like louie had some stupid
[ __ ] written apology
if somebody accuses you of rape bro
i'm on your instagram live i'm on your
instagram
i'm calling takashi like yo what's like
you need to do a music video
how i didn't rape like everybody gonna
find out
not only that you're getting sued your
mother's getting sued
whoever you did the story with getting
sued yeah if you
ever accuse me of some [ __ ] i did not
and then take everything from me
because that's what essentially this is
going to do going over the top over and
over
hey now you would lose to the cycle
real talk so it's like finally someone
came out and they were just like yo you
cannot do this
i thought she was peeing we're good you
cannot do this don't let her distract us
you cannot
you cannot just throw dirt on someone's
name i loved how bieber came
out and bieber was like here's all the
information that got you
into it yeah and sued the [ __ ]
as you should yeah
so the tricky thing about suing people
is it costs mad money
yes if you were to sue the la times
apparently
that's three million dollars it's gonna
cost you a legal fees
apparently now i'm not a [ __ ] lawyer
i don't know i think i just assume
myself do you need a lawyer
can't you just be like you're i'm suing
you
like you can't go to the why did you
guys sue the l.a times can't you just
sue the person
i'm suing everybody but they put out the
piece they put out the piece
if they were lied to and they were
misinformed like you then you get sued
for that you're getting don't get lied
to so much
okay let me do it here let me say this
so someone say some girl
uh some some dude tricked your girl out
of some [ __ ] right
you gonna sue her what what
what what he was talking about this
earlier
exactly exactly your girls to l.a times
some dudes uh you know got a fake story
she buys the fake story
yo yo yo yo it's too late in the
afternoon for y'all
to be a great lawyer
and that's a new name for it you got to
meet oops
i was saying i should have called
dalia's uh me pre
welcome like me
me preteen oh that was the joke i had
this is this don't cut that no that was
the joke i had that was a joke i have
free chris by the way
free chris from everything that came
out he's innocent every time about chris
he free he free he got all the time
he got all the time my man's appointment
book is empty yo but
[Music]
yo he needs to do the front facing video
though real quick
he should do it
i
joke and i didn't put it out because i
got you
well i'm gonna say now because the joke
was fire
all right hit it i get the text mike
feeney informed me about
what happened to callum right tmz feeny
that's what nate tmz
[Applause]
he's there phoenix was there the second
he found out what animal's got some [ __ ]
happening because of bill cosby
i got you so feeny messaged me i'm like
oh no callum went down right
and then and it was for the accusation
was raped
right which he denies i mean on the
phone with me
tons of other things in the conversation
that i cannot share
but very convincing to me again
we're not saying anything about this
girl every girl should be able to you
know
have their voice and nobody's trying to
silence your voice whatever the things i
have to say so you don't think i'm a bad
person
whatever happens in the lawsuit is what
is what it should be
well i don't think there will be a
lawsuit i think it's too expensive
and i think that if you have you know
hundreds of millions of dollars you can
actually do that but
i don't know the point is i have this
joke
right callan has this rape
accusation right and obviously dalia and
i go
uh if dalia and callan's
accusers had a podcast they could call
it the fire
because he's the kid right no no
uh now i'm like i can't put that out
because that's too [ __ ] up and i don't
want to like put any dirt on the man's
name he's already going through a hard
time
now i can't put it outside
i can't put it out it's half a million
but
let's just get it right yeah if his
biggest pocket he doesn't have to be
fair his pieces get about a million so
he's doing that he's doing it
i'm doing it i was talking about a
flagrant episode you know it is what it
is though it's okay you know fast
growing podcasts on the planet it's no
big deal
so uh so but the only reason i say it
right now is because somebody [ __ ]
put it out someone like commented it on
reddit or like instagram or some [ __ ]
and it went viral i was like that's my
[ __ ] [ __ ]
could have been you i know it could have
been me could have been you
no but in all seriousness um
but in all seriousness you know callan's
got literally that's everything going
it's it's yo here's what's also rough go
go
father and there's no you shouldn't if
something happened you got to say
something whatever just what
sucks is if you're innocent and you are
brian yeah you have kids who forever
have to look at you with that accuracy
he's single i was thinking the kids was
worse but yeah
i thought we already did that i thought
we already talked about it
what is being single after doing like
dating after you got the rape
acquisition got to be a lot of kids
you said nothing you went straight to
and new [ __ ]
i thought you covered it i'll be honest
i thought you covered that [ __ ] like a
double stuffed chocolate oreo bro that's
how i thought you had it completely
smothered bruh
completely smothered then i brought in a
new thing which was
dating with the accusation that's got to
make a girl a little bit
bruh i mean the man just got his eyelids
done for [ __ ] sake
imagine all that [ __ ] he gets to see
not
what a poorly timed cosmetic charger no
real like now you wish this [ __ ] was
drooping
[Laughter]
i gotta be killing him back to what
we're saying this is why it's really
tricky just the accusation
no criminal charge just the accession he
can't be on the podcast nope
because of course advertisers are gonna
get spooked and loki
this is why and every single person here
who's part of the patreon
i just want to say thank you i'm sure
akash is eternally grateful as well
everybody here is eternally grateful
this is why i'm not knocking any
advertisers
the advertisers who support this podcast
are absolutely amazing but they also
have a business that they have to
protect
yes so i understand when they have to
make these tough decisions like removing
advertising from a show that they
[ __ ] love
and show where they believe the person
is innocent because of the public
scrutiny surrounding it
they're protecting their brand the only
reason why they're part of the podcast
is to grow their brand
right and if that could detract from the
brand then it's not going to help them
but having a patreon protects
us from those situations where a
complete
somebody that you that you do not know
some random person could
completely lie about this and time will
tell with this situation but someone
could completely lie about you
about me about alex or about mark and
then
take away everything the podcast has
built dude it's rough
it's sad man this [ __ ] up and it's sad
that these things can happen bro
but it's like allegation is true that's
a piece of [ __ ] yes
100 look i feel sorry for the woman
absolutely 100
100 again i can only speak i know brian
yeah so i can't speak on something
if i have someone's phone number who's
involved and i speak on something
without talking to them then i'm stupid
i'm false
i'm a fraud and you shouldn't even
listen to me on this podcast yes if
that's the case i'm not if i'm not
calling the source
to hear about but i don't have shorty's
number
and i'm not an investigative journalist
i can call my boy and say what my boy
says
and i know that there are certain people
out there there's certain podcasts and
i'm not calling out specific podcasts
but
i know when you're in the hollywood
matrix you have to do whatever you can
to protect yourself
because you want to get the job you want
to be on the sitcom you want to be on
the show
so you can't even comment about things
like this
because you could lose the job you could
lose the show you could be
spun in an article you know his friends
are doing all this [ __ ] that's not what
we're about that's not what we're trying
to do
we're literally just trying to have
truth out there and that's what he says
she if she's absolutely entitled to what
she says but he should also be entitled
to what he says yeah
and please believe ellie times not
writing any article about him
yeah and if something comes out about
her lying it's not going to be as big of
an article it just won't grab the same
headlines
right so this guy's got to carry that
with him and i don't even i
understand people who will make the
business decision i'm getting older i
get it
but we didn't want to do that and that's
again where the patreon is so [ __ ]
amazing
is we can speak as honestly as possible
without worrying about
sponsors pulling out or whatever like we
have that thanks you guys it's amazing
yeah so anyway thank you guys so much um
for supporting the patreon man we really
appreciate it patreon.com
flagrant2 this was all advertisement for
our patreon to be honest with you
this really had nothing to do with brian
cowan
the whole thing no not in all serious i
really hope
i mean this is the weirdest this is the
weirdest thing is like i hope
more than anything everything that brian
said to me
is a hundred percent honest 100 true
that's what i what i hope
and it's the weirdest thing when you
talk about this stuff because
you also gotta hope brian's right
because then a girl didn't get raped
yeah yes you know what i'm saying like
nobody should be hoping
that what happened is what the girl said
yes because now you're hoping
that a girl got raped yes and it doesn't
look like there's any criminal charges
or anything going
yes so it is a [ __ ] up situation i
hope what brian is saying is
is 100 true and and uh if that's the
case i hope he gets his life back and i
hope he gets back to doing you know what
he loves to do man i really do
i just hope whatever happened i hope
justice is served that's it that's all
we can hope
absolutely on either end absolutely
you